* Ruhige Musik *
Aus der Ferne betrachtet
sieht Camuns aus wie immer.
Aber das Bild täuscht.
So unberührt das Dorf wirkt,
so radikal hat es sich verändert.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Camuns liegt in der Val Lumnezia,
dem grössten Seitental
des Bündneroberlandes,
der Surselva.
Das Schicksal des kleinen Dorfes
wurde immer wieder mal
öffentlich diskutiert.
Camuns ist ein Beispiel
für so viele Bergbauerndörfer,
die sich in den letzten Jahrzehnten
dramatisch entvölkert haben.
1976 berichtet
das Schweizer Fernsehen:
Sie haben weniger als 100 Einwohner
und tun sich schwer
mit ihren Pflichten,
die 46 Zwerggemeinden in Graubünden.
Sterben diese Gemeinden Fry Rätiens,
z.B. Camuns im Lugnez?
Das ist die Gemeinde von Camuns.
Die roten Häuser sind bewohnt,
die grünen Häuser sind Ferienhäuser,
die weissen Häuser sind leer.
Das ist unsere Kirche,
und das ist unsere Schule.
Insgesamt sind wir 70 Einwohner.
Bewohnte Häuser gibt es 13.
Ferienhäuser: elf.
Leere Häuser sind es drei.
Cordilia Derungs,
die Schülerin von damals,
50 Jahre später.
Hier ging ich zur Schule.
Da hat das Fernsehen damals gefilmt.
Heute hat Camuns noch 27 Einwohner.
Die meisten Häuser
sind in fremden Händen.
Auch das Geburtshaus
von Cordilia Derungs.
Hier sind Sie aufgewachsen?
Ja, in diesem Haus
bin ich aufgewachsen.
Immer noch die Rosen meiner Mutter.
Aber unsere Mutter
hatte noch rundherum Blumen.
Gab das nicht zu reden, als ein Haus
nach dem anderen verkauft wurde?
Doch, aber erst,
als ich schon weg war.
Vorher hatte man
nicht so viel verkauft.
Einige waren auch froh,
verkaufen zu können.
Allmählich stellte ich aber fest,
dass eines nach dem anderen
verkauft wurde.
Man redete schon darüber,
dass Camuns
bald ein totes Dorf sein würde.
Rechts im Bild Elia.
Mit 13 Jahren der jüngste Einwohner
und das einzige Kind in Camuns.
Heute freut er sich über Besuch.
Elia ist der einzige Schüler
von Camuns?
Ja, es wäre schön,
wenn es mehr gäbe.
In Tersnaus
gab es lange keine Kinder,
und jetzt sind es drei.
In Uors
gab es auch lange keine Kinder,
und plötzlich
waren wir zwei bis drei Familien,
jede mit zwei bis vier Kindern.
Es geht in Wellen rauf und runter.
Aber es gab immer wieder Kinder.
Im Nachbardorf Tersnaus
gibt es Bewegung.
Nebst zwei Familien mit Kindern
sind auch einige junge Leute
ins Dorf gekommen.
Joana, Jan und Leander
wollen bleiben und etwas bewegen.
Jan Hermle wuchs in Malans auf.
Er studiert Geografie
und ökologische Landwirtschaft.
Wir hoffen,
dass mehr junge Leute kommen.
Dass es mehr Treffpunkte geben wird
und daraus mehr Initiativen
und Projekte entstehen.
Wie zum Beispiel Konzerte,
vielleicht mal ein Theater
oder ein Diskussionsabend
zu einem politischen Thema.
In diese Richtung.
Leander Albin ist
Schreiner, Lehrer und Musiker.
Er ist in Tersnaus aufgewachsen,
war ein paar Jahre weg
und lebt und arbeitet
seit zwei Jahren wieder hier.
Ich wollte unbedingt weg.
Ich habe irgendwann gemerkt,
dass es mir hier zu klein ist
und zu eng.
Ich wollte sehen, was die Welt
sonst noch zu bieten hat,
wollte reisen, neue Leute treffen.
Ein paar Monate nach London.
Es war die Ferne,
die mich angezogen hat.
Und doch bist du zurückgekommen.
Ja.
Ja, es war vermutlich das Gefühl ...
In der Stadt
fühle ich mich eigentlich sehr wohl.
Mit dem grossen Kulturangebot und
allem, was man so unternehmen kann,
Gross-WGs und so.
Es gibt mir viel,
und ich lerne viel.
Mit der Zeit
habe ich aber auch gemerkt,
dass ich so nicht weiterkomme.
Ich war oft zerrissen zwischen der
Welt hier und der Welt der Stadt.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
zu wenig Zeit hier zu verbringen.
Und ich war zu selten in der Stadt,
um Projekte
auf die Beine stellen zu können.
Ich konnte dort nicht so viel
bewirken, wie ich es hier kann.
Ein selbstbestimmtes Leben
im Einklang mit der Natur.
Das ist heute ein starker Trend,
vor allem
bei jungen Menschen im Unterland.
Die Luzernerin Joana Horni
arbeitet in Vals als Heilpädagogin.
Fühlen Sie sich akzeptiert?
Ja, ich glaube schon.
Ich bin jetzt einfach da.
Aber auf uns
hat hier niemand gewartet.
Wenn man sich bemüht,
mit den Menschen in Kontakt zu tre-
ten und im Dorf etwas organisiert,
wie zum Beispiel
ein Konzert im letzten Sommer
oder ein Suppenessen im Winter,
wird das schon geschätzt.
Jetzt gibt es auch ein paar Junge,
die zugezogen sind.
Ja, ihre WG befindet sich
gleich da hinten.
Es ist schön, wenn sich neue Leute
hier niederlassen.
Das haucht dem Dorf
wieder etwas Leben ein,
bevor uns hier noch alles abstirbt.
Sie sind höflich, so geht das gut.
Und beim Thema Wolf?
Das ist
eine ganz andere Angelegenheit.
Sie sind für den Wolf, ich hingegen
nicht, weil ich ja mein Vieh habe.
Abgesehen von ein paar Ziegen
haben sie keine Tiere,
und die sind mehr ein Hobby.
Ich habe auch schon
mit Joana gesprochen.
Am besten fängt man damit
gar nicht an,
sonst diskutiert man ohne Ende.
Sie sehen das ganz anders.
Das ist das Haus
der Grossmutter von Cordilia Derungs.
Es ist 320 Jahre alt,
und die Renovation
ist ihr grosses Projekt.
Was ist das hier?
Unter diesen Brettern
wurde damals isoliert.
Schau an.
Stark zusammengepresstes Material
wurde damals
zur Isolierung verwendet.
Auch früher
verstanden die Leute ihr Handwerk.
Cordilia Derungs und ihr Mann
haben eine gute Million
Schweizer Franken
in den Umbau investiert.
Zu viele Erinnerungen
sind mit diesem Haus verknüpft.
Es sollte nicht
in fremde Hände kommen.
Die Corona-Zeit hat gezeigt,
viele Leute suchen Wohnraum
in den Bergen.
Aber das ist nicht der Grund,
warum wir das machen,
sondern weil es
das Haus der Grossmutter ist.
Weil wir hier unsere Wurzeln haben.
Deshalb kommen wir wieder zurück.
Und da freuen Sie sich drauf?
- Ja, sehr.
Als Kinder waren wir oft
bei der Grossmutter.
Vor allem im Winter.
Wir konnten mit dem Schlitten
zu ihr fahren,
haben draussen
mit den anderen Kindern gespielt
und warteten,
bis unser Vater nach der Arbeit
aus Ilanz mit dem Auto zurückkam.
Bei der Grossmutter
hat er ein Glas Wein getrunken,
bis wir dann alle zusammen mit
dem Auto nach Hause gefahren sind.
* Ruhige Musik *
Wir hatten viel Freiheit
und wurden nicht ständig behütet.
Mit Vera, Sämmi und Stefan
haben wir bis spät am Abend
Verstecken gespielt.
Es war dunkel,
die Fledermäuse sind geflogen,
und die Eltern haben gesagt,
dass wir jetzt nach Hause müssten,
sonst würden die Fledermäuse
in unsere Haare fliegen
und uns das Blut aussaugen,
was wir
natürlich nicht geglaubt haben.
Vera Schaer-Aeppli
ist eines der Mädchen,
die einst mit Cordilia
Verstecken spielte.
Bis heute verbringt sie ihre Ferien
Jahr für Jahr in Camuns.
Gekauft haben meine Eltern
das Haus 1964.
In jedem Haus lebten alte Leute,
an die ich mich gut erinnere.
Balun, Vincent und Pieder
und da unten Maria und Michel.
Manche waren reserviert,
aber immer freundlich.
Gute Leute, aber zurückhaltend.
Die alten Männer konnten
wohl auch nicht so gut Deutsch.
Maria war aufgeschlossen.
Sie hatte ein offenes Haus, und
wir haben viel Zeit dort verbracht.
Sie hatte
den ersten Fernseher im Dorf,
und wir schauten
den österreichischen Kasperli.
Sie hatte kein Wasser, und wir
hatten den Brunnen vor dem Haus.
Zweimal am Tag kam sie
zum Wasser holen oder Salat waschen.
Da hatte man sowieso viel Kontakt.
Es gab viele Kinder.
Ich habe da oben öfter
mit Kindern gespielt als zu Hause.
Hier waren alle beisammen,
und man hat sich getroffen.
Heute sind alle weg.
Ausser einem Bauern
und seinem Bruder,
aber sonst
sind die Jungen weggezogen.
Teofil Derungs ist einer,
der geblieben ist.
Der Bauer
nähert sich dem Pensionsalter.
40 Jahre lang waren er und seine Frau
tagtäglich eingespannt.
Keiner der beiden Söhne
will den Betrieb übernehmen.
Nun suchen sie einen Pächter.
Noch haben wir keinen Nachfolger.
Ich denke, wenn wir
den Betrieb ausschreiben,
gibt es genug Interessenten.
Dann sehen wir weiter.
Welches
sind die grössten Hindernisse,
um in Camuns
Landwirtschaft zu betreiben?
In unserem Fall ist es das Wohnen.
Es gibt keine Wohnungen.
Aber es gibt doch leere Häuser
hier in Camuns.
Diese Häuser
sind praktisch alle verkauft.
Hier wurden
schon sehr früh Häuser verkauft.
Warum eigentlich?
Keine Ahnung.
Viele sind ausgewandert,
sind in die Stadt gezogen
und haben ihre Häuser verkauft.
Und die Städter kommen zu uns.
So sieht es aus.
* Ruhige Musik *
Vor 50 Jahren ernährte die Viehzucht
14 kinderreiche Familien.
Heute hat Camuns noch drei Bauern.
Dieser Konzentrationsprozess
ging auch in der
scheinbaren Lugnezer Bergidylle
nicht ohne Streitigkeiten ab.
Der Boden ist begrenzt,
und die Agrarpolitik
fordert immer grössere Betriebe.
Es gibt ein romanisches Sprichwort.
"Je kleiner das Wespennest,
umso böser die Wespen."
Läuft's?
- Langsam kommts gut.
Kommt ihr gut aus miteinander?
- Ja, wir haben es gut miteinander.
Und der Kampf um den Boden?
Dieser ist überall gleich.
Die, die schon sehr viel Land haben,
bekommen noch Land dazu.
Und jene, die noch mehr bräuchten,
haben das Nachsehen.
Das ist wie überall.
* Ruhige Musik *
Vor Jahren gab es hier nur Bauern,
und am Alpabzug
war das ganze Dorf beteiligt.
Heute dominieren
ein paar Maschinen das Bild.
Und die Bauern
sind eine kleine Minderheit.
Heute herrscht die Tendenz,
zwei Betriebe
gleichzeitig zu führen.
Langfristig gesehen ist das
sicher nicht gut für die Gesundheit.
Ich habe auch rund 30 Hektar.
Mehr will ich gar nicht.
Sonst schuftet man sich
ja noch zu Tode.
Letztlich geht es um Lebensqualität
und Freude am Beruf.
Hat man zu viel zu tun,
bleibt gar kein Raum für die Freude.
Im Laufe der 1960er- und 1970er-Jahre
kam immer mehr Bauern die Freude
an der Landwirtschaft abhanden.
Einer nach dem anderen
verliess das Dorf.
Ja, die Jungen,
die ein wenig intelligent sind,
bekommen auswärts
eine bessere Existenz
als hier in Camuns als Bauer.
Auch die jungen Frauen
wollen nicht wie ihre Mütter leben.
Zum ersten Mal
in der Geschichte von Camuns
haben sie die Freiheit, über
ihre Zukunft selber zu entscheiden.
Camuns gefällt mir gut als Dorf.
Aber ich möchte hier nicht
als Bäuerin arbeiten.
Ich habe keine Freude daran.
Zukunftspläne habe ich noch keine,
aber ich möchte weg.
Es trifft zu,
dass die Intelligenteren
einen Beruf erlernen und abwandern.
Aber es gibt natürlich auch einige,
die hierbleiben.
Die eine Landwirtschaft führen.
Aber das sind zu wenige,
um eine Gemeinde
lebensfähig zu erhalten.
* Melancholische Musik *
Wir haben vier Kinder,
und die sind alle fortgegangen.
Elf Kinder,
und eine ist dageblieben.
Die anderen sind alle weg?
- Alle.
Mit der Entvölkerung von Camuns
setzt auch
der Ausverkauf der Häuser ein.
Die günstigen Preise
ermöglichen auch Familien
aus bescheidenen Verhältnissen
den Erwerb eines Feriendomizils
in den Bergen.
Im Oktober 1961
hat mein Vater das Haus,
oder besser gesagt,
diese Ruine gekauft.
Was hat sie gekostet?
5'000 Franken,
und die hatte er nicht.
Er musste die Grossmutter anbetteln,
denn er hatte
drei schulpflichtige Kinder.
Ich habe eben vom Grundbuchamt
den damaligen Kaufvertrag bekommen.
Steht der Kaufpreis auch drin?
- Ja.
Wie hoch war er?
25'000 Franken.
Es war in keinem guten Zustand.
Es gab kein Badezimmer.
Es war nicht isoliert.
Wir mussten viel renovieren.
Es herrschte
eine Untergangsstimmung.
In der Presse gab es Berichte,
dass die Jungen aufgefordert wurden,
ins Unterland zu gehen,
und einen Beruf zu erlernen,
da es hier keine Perspektive
für sie gäbe.
Dann wurde die Schule geschlossen,
und die Stimmung blieb negativ.
Als Linus Livers
1991 nach Camuns zieht,
hat man im Dorf seit 14 Jahren
keine Geburt mehr verzeichnet.
Meine Frau und ich kamen 1991
mit zwei Kindern hierher.
Wir hatten das Glück, dass man hier
in Camuns eine Stelle kreiert hatte,
um eine Familie anzulocken.
Die Stelle ist entstanden,
indem man die Post und die Kanzlei
zusammengelegt hat.
Zusammen ergab dies
eine 100-%-Stelle.
Meine Frau und ich
haben sie geteilt.
Sie hat 40 % Kanzlei gemacht
und ich 60 % den Postschalter.
Anfangs waren hier 44 Personen.
Unsere vierköpfige Familie stellte
fast 10 % der Bevölkerung dar.
Dann haben wir selber
aktiv angefangen zu suchen.
Wir haben überall nach Wohnungen
und möglichen Interessenten
nachgefragt.
Am Schluss sind noch
ein paar Familien dazugekommen,
und in Camuns lebten 15 Kinder.
Aber alle etwa im gleichen Alter.
Sie wurden älter, sind weggezogen,
und wir Alten blieben zurück.
Und jetzt hoffen wir erneut,
dass es irgendwie weitergeht
und das Dorf nicht ausstirbt.
Auch Cordilia Derungs
war damals gegangen.
Die Schülerin, die im Fernsehfilm
ihr Dorf so souverän erklärte,
hat im Unterland Karriere gemacht.
Die ausgebildete Logopädin
ist eine gefragte Spezialistin
für Autismus.
Ja, hier ist es wunderschön,
und wir geniessen es auch.
Aber so schön es ist,
die Berge, die Weite,
das einfache Leben vielleicht,
die Ruhe.
Ja, es zieht uns einfach zurück.
Dann werden wir sehen, wie es wird,
und ob wir mit der Ruhe
auch umgehen können.
Vorläufig aber
lebt Cordilia Derungs
noch in Oetwil an der Limmat,
zusammen mit ihrem Mann
Daniel Cathomen.
Er ist Marketingleiter eines global
tätigen Beleuchtungsunternehmens.
Teilt Daniel Ihre Begeisterung,
nach Camuns zu ziehen?
Ja, jetzt schon.
Vor ein paar Jahren
war es noch etwas schwierig für ihn.
Er hatte das Gefühl,
Camuns sei zu abgelegen.
Wir haben uns etwas Zeit gelassen,
und mit den Jahren hat er gemerkt,
wie schön Camuns ist,
und wie schön mein Herz schlägt.
Und dann war er einverstanden,
das Haus umzubauen.
Es freut mich riesig,
dass wir dies nun machen können.
Lief das so ab?
Ja, dahinter ist natürlich
immer ein Prozess.
In jungen Jahren
hat man anders funktioniert.
Das ist normal.
Es gibt etwas,
das wir seit Jahren feststellen,
und zwar je länger, je mehr.
Trotz der weiten Distanz,
die wir aus beruflichen Gründen
von oben entfernt sind,
jedes Mal während der Ferien
merkt man,
dass hier etwas mitschwingt.
Eine Energie,
in der man sich wohlfühlt.
Es ist die Mentalität, die Kultur,
die Landschaft.
Die Wurzeln sind dort,
sie sind spürbar.
Dies spricht natürlich nicht
gegen das, was wir hier haben,
aber oben ist einfach eine Kraft da,
von der wir sagen:
"Hier fühlen wir uns wohl."
Daher ist es naheliegend,
dass wir nach Camuns ziehen.
* Ruhige Musik *
Auch im Winter
bleibt Camuns mit der Welt verbunden.
Aber die Natur
wagt sich in der kalten Jahreszeit
noch näher ans Dorf.
Teofil Derungs ist zufrieden.
Er hat einen Pächter
für seinen Betrieb gefunden.
Sind Sie froh?
Ja, ich bin sehr froh,
dass wir jemanden gefunden haben.
Gute Nachfolger?
Das wird sich zeigen,
aber ich denke schon.
Aus der Gegend?
Ja, der Bauer kommt aus der Gegend.
Seine Freundin
kommt aus dem Unterland.
Sie haben
ein riesiges Interesse am Betrieb.
Und wie sieht es mit dem Wohnen aus?
Das ist das Problem.
Da sind wir aber auch dran.
Vielleicht ... Wir hoffen es.
Vielleicht was?
Eben, dass wir das Haus bekommen,
das wir in Aussicht haben.
Welches ist es denn?
- Das Gemeindehaus.
Neben Teofil Derungs Heim
steht das fragliche Haus.
Es gehört der Gemeinde und ist seit
Jahren an Unterländergäste vermietet.
Nun sollen sie
einer Bauernfamilie Platz machen.
Dort ist praktisch jedes Wochenende
jemand anderes im Haus.
Und das wäre eine Familie,
die das ganze Jahr hier wäre.
Ich finde es eigentlich sinnvoller,
es so zu vermieten.
Wann kommt das raus?
Im Sommer irgendwann.
Hoffe ich.
* Ruhige Musik *
* Gesprächsfetzen *
In Tersnaus hat Familie Albin
einen sanften Agrotourismus
aufgebaut.
Wir treffen Edith Albin,
die vor 30 Jahren
aus Deutschland zugewandert ist.
Die Gäste werden nicht
als Fremde wahrgenommen.
Sie sind vielmehr eingeladen,
den Bergbauernalltag
aus der Nähe kennenzulernen.
Und als Unterkunft
dient das alte Schulhaus.
Es ist bereits das dritte Jahr,
in dem wir hier bei Edith und Robert
im Schulzimmer
unsere Ferien verbringen.
Meist im Winter.
Und ab und zu im Sommer.
Und einmal an Ostern.
- Ja, an Ostern.
Wir haben schon Ostereier gesucht.
Wir wollen ein wenig die Welt
in unser kleines Dorf holen.
Und wir suchen den Kulturaustausch.
Wir wollen etwas
von unserer Welt geben
und von der Welt der anderen
etwas bekommen.
Wir haben einen regen Austausch,
auch über das, was wir machen.
Warum wir es machen,
wie wir es machen,
was unsere Motivationen sind.
Und das gibt gemeinsame,
wunderschöne und intensive Gespräche
und Erlebnisse.
* Gesprächsfetzen *
Aber Familie Albin hat Ziele,
die über den Agrotourismus
hinausgehen.
Ein grosses Anliegen ist,
unsere alten Häuser aus der Familie
jungen Menschen
zu Verfügung zu stellen,
um ihnen zu ermöglichen,
zu uns ins Dorf zu kommen
zum dauerhaften Wohnen.
Nicht als Zweitwohnsitz, sondern
als permanente Wohnbevölkerung.
Joana, Jan und Leander
haben im Dorf eine Bleibe gefunden.
In einem der Häuser
der Familie Albin.
Ich finde es wunderbar,
so viel draussen sein zu können,
in der Natur.
Diese auch zu spüren.
Wenn möglich, essen wir draussen.
Jan und ich klettern
oder machen Skitouren.
Dann sind wir auch immer draussen.
Es ist die Nähe zur Natur
und so schnell
so weit draussen sein zu können.
Dass, wenn ich
da hinten alleine hochlaufe,
mir eine Gämse über den Weg läuft,
ich Wolfsspuren sehe
oder einen Kadaver,
an dem gerade
ein Luchs gefressen hat.
Hier ist der Wald noch ein Wald.
Das ist sehr schön.
* Gesprächsfetzen *
Der Gedanke des Dorfes gefällt mir.
Dass es eine Gemeinschaft gibt
mit verschiedenen Menschen
und Hintergründen.
Die, die geblieben sind,
diejenigen,
die dazustossen oder zurückkommen,
das ergibt für mich
ein grosses Potenzial, um ...
... um vielleicht der Gesellschaft
ein wenig vorzuleben,
wie es auch funktionieren kann.
Dass wir uns nicht alle entfremden,
und dass es
keinen Stadt-Land-Graben gibt.
Das ist spannend.
* Musik *
Hier hat sich
inzwischen einiges verändert.
Der Innenausbau
ist so weit fortgeschritten,
dass Cordilia Derungs und ihr Mann
einziehen konnten.
Danke.
- Sehr gern.
Das zur Ruhe kommen ist einzigartig.
Hier funktioniert man ganz anders.
Man kocht zusammen,
hat Gäste, Freunde,
man geht im Winter Skifahren.
Ich habe in dieser inspirierenden
Umgebung wieder angefangen,
Musik zu machen.
Ich habe meine Gitarre entstaubt
und widme mich erneut diesem Hobby.
* Blues-Rhythmen *
Wir haben viele Ideen.
Familien mit Autismus unterstützen,
eine Gaststätte
für Radfahrer oder Wanderer.
Schlussendlich schauen wir,
was sich ergibt.
Alles kann man nicht vorausplanen.
Man muss gewisse Dinge
auch entstehen lassen.
Vermieten?
Den oberen Teil des Hauses
vermieten wir nicht.
Wenn, dann nur die untere Wohnung.
Kann sein, dass hier
mal jemand dauerhaft wohnen wird.
Vielleicht eine Familie.
Das ist aber noch am Entstehen.
* Ruhige Musik *
In den letzten Jahren
haben zwei Faktoren
die Nachfrage nach altem Baubestand
in den Berggebieten enorm gesteigert.
Die Zweitwohnungs-Initiative,
welche Neubauten
vielerorts verhindert,
und die Corona-Pandemie,
welche eine veritable Fluchtbewegung
Richtung Alpen ausgelöst hat.
Die Hauspreise
gingen durch die Decke.
Tersnaus ist
eines der wenigen Dörfer,
die noch nicht
gänzlich ausverkauft sind.
Der Zweitwohnungsanteil
ist hier mit 30 % relativ klein.
Auf Initiative der WG
trifft sich die Einwohnerschaft
von Tersnaus zum Gedankenaustausch.
Wie soll es weitergehen
mit ihrem Dorf?
Die Wunschliste
benennt das wichtigste Defizit.
Wir mussten auch
sehr lange ein Haus suchen.
Ich kenne viele, die gerne
in die Berge ziehen würden.
Es gibt aber
kaum mehr bezahlbaren Wohnraum.
Für junge Leute,
die noch kein Haus kaufen wollen,
ist es fast unmöglich, an
einem solchen Ort etwas zu mieten.
Dann muss man halt nach Chur
in eine Blockwohnung,
wenn man in die Berge möchte.
Aber das ist nicht,
was ich gesucht habe.
Auch meine Freunde, die gerne
in den Bergen wohnen würden,
suchen keine Wohnung
in einer Provinzstadt.
Eine Gruppe junger Leute
trifft sich in Tersnaus,
um Lösungsmöglichkeiten zu suchen.
Sie haben Fachleute
aus der Stadt eingeladen.
Eine Genossenschaft
ist für ein Wohnprojekt das Beste.
Man hat sehr gute Möglichkeiten,
um an Geld zu kommen.
Wenn es um Geld geht,
schaut jeder meistens für sich.
Das gilt auch
für die einheimischen Hausverkäufer.
Was wir feststellen:
Es ist für sie schon wichtig,
dass es weiterhin
bewohnten Wohnraum gibt.
Wenn aber jemand für ein Ferienhaus
das Dreifache bietet,
überlegen sie es sich
natürlich schon.
Und dann kommt dann doch erst
das Fressen und dann die Moral.
Das heute gibt viel Anfangsenergie.
Es gibt noch Häuser.
Es gibt noch nicht
so viel Tourismus,
weil wir keine Skilifte haben.
Und es sind megacoole Leute im Dorf.
Und auch in den umliegenden Dörfern,
die es schätzen, wenn junge Leute,
aber auch Ältere, hier sein wollen.
Hier leben
und sich einbringen wollen.
Diese Verankerung zu spüren
und zu merken,
dass das von den Leuten
getragen wird,
ist schön
und lässt uns Hoffnung schöpfen.
Aber eben, heute kam die Frage auf,
ob man die Gemeinde
involvieren sollte.
Da habe ich keine Ahnung,
ob diese überhaupt
ein Interesse daran hat.
Daniel Soler
ist Präsident der Gemeinde Lumnezia.
Ihm ist das Problem durchaus bewusst.
Je höher der Anteil an
meist leerstehenden Zweitwohnungen,
desto drückender der Mangel
an bezahlbarem Wohnraum
für Einheimische.
Wir sind dran, aktiv Land zu kaufen,
auch von Privaten,
und bezahlbares Land
dann im Baurecht Familien abzugeben.
Allenfalls bauen wir selber.
Vielleicht können Genossenschaften
gebildet werden,
die Einheimischen und jungen
Familien Land zu Verfügung stellen,
zu einem guten und zahlbaren Preis.
Würde die Gemeinde
einesolche WG unterstützen?
Da müssten wir zunächst wissen,
was sie vorhaben,
und wie das Ganze aussieht.
Wir hören uns ihr Anliegen
mit offenen Ohren an.
Sie sollen zu uns kommen.
Wenn das Konzept gut ist,
wären wir bereit,
das Vorhaben zu unterstützen.
* Ruhige Musik *
Das sind bemerkenswert neue Töne.
Noch vor wenigen Jahren
wäre eine Wohngemeinschaft
junger Leute von auswärts
wohl auf wenig Verständnis gestossen.
Vor zehn Jahren
haben wir wirklich gedacht:
"Wow, was ist das für ein Ort!"
Aber was ich heute feststelle, ist,
dass die Bevölkerung
durch den Wegzug von vielen
offener geworden ist gegenüber
neuen Menschen, die hierher kommen.
Da hat es wirklich
einen Wandel gegeben.
Und in der Gesellschaft
hat sich einiges verändert,
sodass das Dorf
noch eine Chance haben
und wieder
einen Aufschwung bekommen könnte.
Jetzt sieht es so aus.
Aber es kann
in beide Richtungen gehen.
Teofil Derungs hat von der Gemeinde
guten Bescheid bekommen.
Sein junges Pächterpaar
kann ins Gemeindehaus einziehen.
Die Dorfbevölkerung von Camuns
nimmt zu.
Zum letzten Mal bringt er
mit seiner Frau die Heuernte ein
und erinnert sich.
Als ich den Betrieb übernommen habe,
hatten wir an die zehn Hektar Land,
zwei bis drei Kühe
und etwas Jungvieh.
Dann wurde der Betrieb
von Jahr zu Jahr grösser.
Ich bekam hier und da
etwas Land dazu.
Auch auswärts
habe ich welches bewirtschaftet.
Später bekamen wir hier Land.
Früher waren wir
ein paar Leute auf dem Feld.
Die Eltern haben auch mitgeholfen.
Ich mähte mit dem Mäher
und meine Eltern mit der Sense.
Den ganzen Vormittag.
Heutzutage machst du das nicht mehr.
Eigentlich sind wir tagsüber
meist nur zu zweit.
Früher hat man im Dorf
noch Menschen getroffen.
Jetzt siehst du
praktisch niemanden mehr.
Früher konnte man im Dorf
noch ein, zwei Gespräche führen.
Jetzt nur noch,
wenn die Fremden da sind.
Mit ihnen kann man schon
in ein Gespräch kommen.
Aber was ist mit dem Dorfleben?
Dem Camunser Leben?
Das ist vorbei.
Verglichen mit früher
ist jetzt nichts mehr.
Es ist auch nicht so, dass ihr
untereinander grossen Kontakt habt?
Nein, wir haben
praktisch keinen Kontakt mehr.
Ab und zu
siehst du jemanden vorbeifahren.
Schade, dass es nicht mehr ist.
* Kirchenglocke schlägt. *
Auf dem Friedhof
wurden viele Gräber aufgelöst.
Ich habe alle gekannt.
Es ist ein Wahnsinn.
Das Dorf stirbt aus.
Früher war es lebendig,
mit zwei Kneipen und einer Post.
Hier war der Laden, der am Donner-
stag und am Samstag geöffnet hatte.
Da vorne lebten fünf Kinder,
dort hinten 13.
Das Dorf war voller Kinder.
Damals.
* Hämmern *
Die WG von Tersnaus
will unter anderem
jungen Leuten aus dem Unterland
das Probewohnen im Berggebiet
ermöglichen.
Unsere Idee ist es,
aus diesem Raum
einen Gemeinschaftsraum zu machen.
Und im kleinen Zimmer da hinten
ein weiteres Schlafzimmer.
Damit ein bis zwei Personen mehr
im Haus wohnen können.
Ein Haus wurde gerade verkauft.
Das geht schnell.
Wir wissen, dass es erneut
eine Ferienwohnung geben wird.
Damit fällt wieder ein Stück Wohn-
raum zur permanenten Nutzung weg.
Das Haus war für über eine Million
ausgeschrieben.
Vor fünf Jahren hätte es
ein Viertel davon gekostet.
Aber mal sehen, wer es ist.
Wir kennen
die neuen Besitzer noch nicht.
Vielleicht sind sie
supersympathisch.
Schlussendlich
müssen wir diejenigen,
die zu uns in die Ferien kommen,
trotzdem willkommen heissen
und das Beste daraus machen.
Klar ist es ein Frust.
Aber vielleicht ist es jemand,
der sich für das Leben hier
interessiert.
Dann kann das fürs Dorf
auch ein Gewinn sein.
Wir müssen versuchen,
es so zu sehen:
Nicht nur die, die hier wohnen,
sind etwas wert.
Andreas Albin gefällt es in Tersnaus,
so wie es ist.
Die WG beobachtet er mit Interesse,
aber auch mit einer leisen Skepsis.
Schon recht, wenn Leute zuziehen.
Die machen aber auch nicht viel
für die Dorfentwicklung.
Sie leben einfach und haben
vielleicht nicht die Mittel,
eine Familie mit Kindern
aufzuziehen.
So entwickelt sich das Dorf
kaum weiter,
wenn nur ein paar wenige kommen.
Viel ändert sich
meiner Meinung nach nicht.
Es sind aber Junge, die kommen.
Ja, jung sind sie.
So bleiben sie vielleicht
dem Dorf länger erhalten.
Kann sein, dass sie länger bleiben,
wenn sie nicht plötzlich
wieder verschwinden.
Derweil versuchen Jan und Leander,
eine alte Maschine
zum Leben zu erwecken.
Sie bereiten ein Theaterstück vor,
in welchem der alte Heuwender
als Perkussionist auftritt.
Im Moment ist es gut,
und gleichwohl ist mir bewusst,
dass sich alles
immer wieder verändert.
Ich denke gar nicht so viel
an die Zukunft, seit ich hier bin.
Ich habe die letzten Jahre oft
in der Stadt gewohnt und gewünscht,
in die Berge zu ziehen.
Ich war immer
in die Zukunft gerichtet,
habe ein Haus in den Bergen gesucht,
und jetzt bin ich hier,
und jetzt ist es auch mal gut.
Ich bin nun da,
mache meine Sachen und geniesse es,
nicht wieder
vom Nächsten träumen zu müssen.
In Camuns wird Grossmutters
renoviertes Haus eingeweiht.
Also ...
Es freut mich sehr,
dass wir alle zusammen sein können.
Aber noch mehr freut uns die tolle
Arbeit, die ihr geliefert habt.
Vielen Dank.
Das Haus hat Charakter.
Man spürt das Haus.
- Man spürt das Haus.
Das sagen auch die Arbeiter,
die hier waren.
In diesem Haus
fühlt man sich einfach wohl.
320 Jahre
haben Menschen darin gelebt.
Diese Aura spürt man
in jedem Zimmer, von oben bis unten.
Man kann es nicht beschreiben.
Es ist wirklich schön.
Dieser Backofen lieferte einst
das Brot für 30 Hausbewohner.
Heute gibt es Pizza.
Die Leute, die die alten Häuser
aufkaufen und umbauen,
haben erwachsene Kinder.
Sie bringen keine Kinder mit.
Demzufolge gibt es auch
keine Schule.
Auf der anderen Seite finden junge
Familien, die gern herkommen würden,
keine Wohnungen zum Mieten,
geschweige denn zum Kaufen.
Das wären die, die Kinder haben
und die Schulen beleben könnten.
Es sind diese widersprüchlichen
Pole, die sich im Wege stehen.
Das Ganze
ist eine sehr grosse Frage,
die politisch-wirtschaftlich
gelöst werden muss.
Wir können da kaum etwas beitragen,
aber etwas muss passieren.
* Live-Musik *
Unser letzter Besuch
führt uns ans Kulturfestival Buatsch,
das die WG von Tersnaus
zusammen mit vielen Freiwilligen
von auswärts
seit 2018 organisiert.
Das kulinarische Angebot ist vegan.
Die Preise sind nicht bindend.
Es geht darum,
dass alle so viel geben,
wie sie können.
Dass wir nicht davon ausgehen,
dass alle gleich viel Geld haben.
Und dass das Festival
für alle zugänglich ist.
Auch die, die gar kein Geld haben,
sollen kommen können.
Habt ihr auch die Hoffnung,
dass vielleicht
der eine oder die andere sagt:
"Ich ziehe nach Tersnaus"?
Hoffnung nicht unbedingt,
aber letztlich sind die,
die das Festival schon
vor drei Jahren organisiert haben,
auch die,
die heute in Tersnaus wohnen.
Es gibt dem Ort etwas,
ein anderes Gefühl,
eine Perspektive,
was hier möglich ist.
Es ist ein Teil unseres Projektes.
Musik ist nicht so meins.
Diese Art Musik sowieso nicht.
Aber finden Sie,
dass sie es gut organisiert haben?
Ich brauche das nicht.
Es ist eher was für die Kollegen
der WG aus dem Unterland.
Von mir aus könnten sie das
auch woanders machen.
Es schadet aber sicher nicht.
Einigen Einheimischen
gefällt das vielleicht.
Wer will, kann da hingehen
und sich das Ganze anschauen
und geniessen.
Es ist eine riesige Freude.
Sie überzeugen mich
mit dem Herzblut,
mit dem sie bei der Sache sind,
und vor allem auch
mit ihrem Gemeinschaftsgeist.
Was die auf die Beine stellen,
ist grossartig.
Ob das so bleibt, wissen wir nicht.
Aber dass ein neuer Schwung da ist
und Neues entstehen kann,
das zeigt das Festival.
Wir sind sehr offen
und auch hoffnungsvoll.
Die rege Beteiligung
aus dem Unterland weckt Hoffnungen.
Wird es Joana,
Jan und Leander gelingen,
auf Dauer
neues Leben nach Tersnaus zu bringen?
In Camuns wird sich in den nächsten
Jahren wohl nicht viel ändern.
Das Dorf ist ausverkauft.
Untertitelung: Iyuno
im Auftrag von SWISS TXT - 2022